what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation John how are you I'm so
eerie and and uh you know out there
today yeah let's not stall as we get to
Gravity Falls you know what to do be dip
your hand to that like button and if
you're capable like Mabel you know
subscribe and click that notification
Bell that maybell and don't be a grump
if you're a Grunkle Stan come over to
our patreon and watch the full length
sync up with your own copy watch along
we got other shows there as well
and um don't snooze like Zeus
if you're looking for editing help from
prep all right let's do it
[Music]
is it the message that we're getting too
old for this sort of thing
um kind of actually it's that we are
exactly one week away from our 13th
birthday
[Applause]
to be with Wendy our birthday's coming
up already soon we're gonna be actual
teenagers finally I can stop reading
preteen magazine and start reading post
pre-teen magazines
one more year until high school high
school Dipper we're girls become women
and they teach us stuff about you know
what trigonometry oh yeah
you're doing the voice so you obviously
know what I'm talking about but you're
booking about
there is something wrong with you
talk with both of us what's gonna happen
I don't know but there's nothing googly
eyes can't make more fun we need to
throw the greatest party of all time I'm
talking pinatas with tinier pinatas
inside boom dreams coming to us
exciting everyone in town let's see
where do we stand with the gnomes not so
fast Goofus and girl Goofus after that
zombie incident no one's throwing
another party at my house callback who
could run out to Gravity Falls High
School gym and have your party there
that place is empty all summer long the
Gym's a great idea Zeus to the high
school
great uncle Ford are you okay oh yes I'm
fine I just said that to make sure you
come in here quickly but your face is on
fire yes it's much faster than shaving
now listen Dipper and try that remember
the rift and dimensional space time I
showed you
it's cracking this is what bill has been
waiting for if it breaks it would cause
reality as we know it to completely
unravel put it in a box
but for the sake of humanity we mustn't
let it what do we do we patch the rift
I'll explain on the way what about Mabel
it's okay Dipper you should totally go
with grunkleford to save the world or
whatever are you sure
[Laughter]
plus I practice walkie talkies here's
one for my party mission and one for
your smarty Mission
I did mention that the fate of the
universe is at stake didn't I haven't
much time okay Deborah it's your first
big mission with Ford a chance to prove
yourself don't mess this up
oh yeah High School is the worst classes
get super hard and worst of all
everybody hates you
uh anyway what are you guys doing here
looking for a place to have my 13th
birthday party Wendy borderoy I mean
corduroy isn't it I mean
don't despair we can have our party at
the gym but we gotta talk about high
school I'm starting to think it might
not be the awesome future we were
expecting
when I get back your problems are tiny
Mabel look at the peculiar shape made by
those Cliffs does it remind you of
anything
[Music]
shut up
did this craft cause the town's strange
Properties or did the town's strange
properties attract the crash the answer
is still unknown where did the saucer go
sometimes the strangest things in the
world are right under our noses
crashed into Fry's Electronics
this word's not working from mouth all
makes sense
I wish my mind could be where yours is
right now Dipper when confirmation of
extraterrestrial still had that punch
now it's just sort of
[Music]
wow the gucker and I used to come down
here all the time to raid their Tech and
study their language
this is so cool Russian
yeah that's gonna come in handy also if
it touches you it will seal up all the
orifices in your face so try to avoid
that now use your magnet gun and follow
me
[Music]
your turn
it helps
okay just turn on magnet leap down hole
come on already
magnet
[Music]
a little help
this is how I fail video game levels but
at least we've you can write candy
music camp this time of year and
oh Marius now's not the time
go ahead flip any switch they've all
been busted for millions of years
Netflix just the right trust me I'd love
to fast forward the whole thing but it's
not like I have a choice I'm getting too
old to investigate Gravity Falls on my
own I need to train an apprentice to
help me fight monsters solve Mysteries
protect this town oh no I'd like to keep
it in the family I've read your
additions to my journal and I'm
impressed with your potential what would
you say to staying in Gravity Falls
after the summer end and becoming my
Apprentice but what about Mabel you
never felt like you were meant for
something more sounds like a dream come
true but I was tricked by Bill I was
wrong about Stan's portal heck I can't
even operate this magnet gun right
failure is a part of the Learning lesson
yes
yes
for this
their hand is touching the adhesive yeah
I've studied these they're security
droids and they detect adrenaline you
simply have to not feel any fear and
they won't
just take a deep breath focus on your
intellect and control your fear
critical forward Focus Dipper
I I
down way to go different stay back it's
too dangerous sealing the rift is what's
important now take this no
[Music]
use the adhesive fix the rift save the
universe Dipper
don't
[Music]
don't live on Earth are you doing ugh
oh my goodness
Toto we're not in Gravity Falls anymore
[Music]
you are ruining Mabel's birthday okay
let's try Dragon Balls
yes
EMP they're gonna crack the glass on the
nothing in this universe is gonna take
away my uncle give me what you got
foreign
[Music]
son of a [ __ ] you're an American
territory yeah we don't feel fear in
America
the orb didn't detect any chemical signs
of fear it assumed the threat was
neutralized and then self-disassembled I
did it you did it check the orb check
the what I was talking about how many
other 12 year olds do you think are
capable of doing what you've just done
but is there monetary game can I make a
living out of this but I don't want to
say goodbye to Gravity Falls you'll
still have your brother along with you
through thick and thin at least when I
go home I always have dipper this town
is a magnet for things that are special
and that includes you and me it brought
both of us here of Attraction become my
Apprentice don't let anyone hold you
I'll do it I'm gonna stay now who wants
to save the world
you really should check your your
backpack what's Apprentice
I was think
ing opportunity for me oh I didn't mean
it like that maybe we'll come back
[Music]
we're about to go into the weirdmageddon
aren't we yep only party chocolate can
cheer me up now nerd books to the pins
uh wrong backpack it's not fair I just
wish summer could last forever oh no it
might be possible sweater town is not
accepting incoming calls right now
Mabel it's me
what yeah he's doing it I need to think
about this Dipper right now we need to
focus on the mission now come on I've
got the glue hand me the rift and let's
make history what
oh no the rift
oh Lord is this it yes that's it just
hand it over and I'll do my thing just a
little more summer
[Music]
gate Between Worlds has opened the event
won billion years prophesied has come to
pass the world is
[Music]
oh no holy crap weird again
the truth unveiled
what's going on
we're too late
it's pretty scary yeah it's pretty
ominous [ __ ]
got intense there one note to end on
seriously
whoo
kind of gonna relax my shoulders
okay
relax I am
take it away dude this was quite a
harrowing little episode right here and
I liked the way that they juxtaposed a
very personal end of the world with a
very literal end of the world
and you know the seasons come into a
close we're almost at the end
and I felt like that was a good way to
you know paying our emotions because I'm
gonna miss summer in Gravity Falls
and uh yeah you know it's uh
the end times are nigh
what do you think sir yeah I think that
everything about it was a really solid
episode
sure yeah uh I I really enjoy seeing the
Extraterrestrial Department of it and uh
on unpacking that as like oh it's kind
of like really spielbergian in the way
how that was all crafted together and
you know I I like what Ford is doing
because
he has his own type of personal
experience he's drawing from with his
own brother and he's clearly projecting
that onto Dipper as she you know she's
she's like your Grunkle Stan and the way
they've juxtaposed that and drawn the
parallels of how much Mabel really
connects with her Uncle Stan and how
much more Dipper connects with uh Ford
but doesn't they don't uh like shove
that in your face but that is a thing of
note to say the least so I I think the
way they did handle it like you said a
good personal side of it and and having
something that does feel really big
Stakes at the end and a frustrating
moment for Maple right there because I'm
like yeah this is exactly why this is
kind of [ __ ]
I'm feeling like hold back just making
mistakes like this but I feel like
they're gonna wrap it around because you
know we always get moments eventually
where Mabel will do something heroic or
greater Grand to show that now they do
belong together as a unit and I'm hoping
that Dipper does make I like the mature
theme of it of you know you have to
eventually Grove apart and you know
maybe you don't have to grow apart but
sometimes you are destined for different
paths just because you're family just
because your siblings doesn't mean you
know if you're both siblings you should
both start up a YouTube reaction Channel
you know yeah
carve your own way Mabel damn so every
once in a while somebody will do that
so yeah once in a while I think that it
was a very I think that it was a really
strong and grossing and uh I I actually
don't know what decision I want them to
make personally I'm totally fine with
Dipper staying behind and excelling in
this realm because he clearly has an
excitement for it and I just started
going down the road in my own head of
man I feel like you become really
resentful towards your sibling if you
sacrifice something that you thought you
could be incredibly great at because you
have a sibling who just doesn't know how
to take care of themselves you know if
that's like the early stages granted
they're kids you know so you always feel
like you want an older brother around
but you know what happens when you're
adults what if that was a missed
opportunity what if he took that chance
as a kid and he could be a famous Rich
scientist who will impact some of the
world's greatest secrets and discoveries
but sacrifice it all so yeah I think it
actually posed some very mature
questions and and in a way that was very
contemplative for myself here because I
know as an audience member I should be
like you know Dipper I'm able to stick
together that's the unit but at the end
of the day I'm like yeah maybe not
though you know so yeah I thought this
was really well done and uh High School
I I can't relate with the experience of
high school barely went but look at me
now so yeah it's another great example
you don't need high school kids if
you're watching it's a waste of time and
money well if it's public it's not money
but it's a waste of time and you could
probably just do something else more
valuable
um yeah it's good stuff my question is
why can't Mabel just also stay she seems
to quite enjoy Gravity Falls why can't
she just stay with him she has to be
with her loving parents
that Dipper just doesn't yeah same age
kid just doesn't I mean there's a deal
they would not they would they would go
home after summer maybe they both can
stay maybe this is where their real home
is at where all the terror lives it
seems like they're both well suited to
this place for different reasons you
know in some ways it's actual terrible
guardianship of I mean Grunkle Stan we
also we're always known as a terrible
Guardian but the
but you know for foreign to put a 12
year old and this level of peril all the
time and the weight of world impending
doom literally on the weight of a 12
year old that's just not right sure so I
mean there's a lot of really
contemplated questions that I think they
asked were quite mature and I respect
the show for going down that route and
it was uh it was reasonably funny but uh
exciting at the same time yeah so yeah
it was a really great episode yeah it's
well aimed and I think the world
mcgetting part is I mean we're to be
getting where are you getting we're
getting is either weird again or
weirdmageddon or something like that
either one I mean I hope that it
continues to be like a certain type of I
was like I mean we're at the we're at
the end here so we could spend like the
rest of the show there could we
theoretically having the fabric of space
and time altered look think of how many
surreal animatics we could get and how
many different beings we could see
beyond Bill Cipher I mean he's must have
a a whole codery of nightmares awaiting
for them inside the rift I mean at the
same time though I do think it was
negligent of
uh
what's a great uncle Ford and Dipper to
not have informed anyone in the house
about hey you should be mindful of this
do not let it break you know it doesn't
hurt if you don't want them on the
mission that makes sense but at the same
time you gotta have a watchful lie and
you know how careless a lot of them can
be and how
uh raucous
raucous
now raucas they can be and
that type of behavior could lead to
things being damaged in in the home sure
I mean hell there's that as an episode
established we're still finding zombie
bits he's saying you know in between
couches when really it was like right
underneath the couch cushion yeah it's
not something it's just stuck in between
like dude you can just lift up back and
you got that kind of behavior in a
household you should be you should warn
people you should put up signs yeah
let's say if you see this let one of us
know and don't mess with it because
because bad things will happen yeah so
it's a strong start to what it could be
a a very fascinating compelling finale
and uh what it looks like it's probably
gonna be very emotional at the same time
I know we're gonna all come of age
alongside Dipper and my bell
why are you being so sarcastic
I just can't help myself you know I I
really struggle with sincerity
especially when we're talking about you
know yeah family entertainment I just
can't you know I feel like there's
already too much sincerity and if you
want to be on The Cutting Edge of humor
got to be sarcastic you got to be ironic
and uh you got to be insincere
I feel like I made really valid points I
forgot everything I said like you did
I think you did I'm not trying to argue
with you I'm just uh I'm just relishing
in my native tone
now
that I like to use is weird I feel like
people are gonna think I'm sarcastic
yeah now No One's Gonna know who's you
was in line with their actual thoughts
those were my actual thoughts I feel
like I broke down I feel like you did
the questions that were poised to us
absolutely you did
I don't know if you don't respect me
then I don't respect you
who's who you have to respect like
siblings siblings don't have to respect
each other
you respect your sister do you sleep in
the same bed with her until you're like
18.
we still do you know it's uh it's just
more doesn't even live there anymore no
no it's a real inconvenience for me it's
a real difficult drive over every night
just sleep at the same food we just
finished She-Hulk at six a.m move over
move over I know you got to be up in an
hour with me nah make a space
that's right man never going to high
school
also I did appreciate uh who voices
um Rick and Morty oh Justin Horizon
Justin royland I appreciate Justin
royland actually not because I love Rick
and Morty I really I'm not caught up to
date with the latest season
um I just started airing uh I do love
Rick and Morty a lot but I was kind of
worried that Justin Roiland was gonna
like show up do his thing and kind of
distract
and I was like oh no I actually liked it
he's just doing his little guest
appearance he's doing it straightforward
and since you're not trying to be funny
yeah and I'm just giving the alley-oop
yeah yeah I thought that was really I
really appreciated that yeah and it was
like the right it was a good character
for that mislead
because it's so obvious that wasn't a
mystery it was obvious as [ __ ] it was
Bill Cipher well yeah absolutely not
well I that bit though I was like oh is
he you know obviously he knows what the
thrift is
because he's inside Charlie he can do
anything I'm gonna be there at the right
time the right conversation yeah because
he because he could know this is the
point in history that the rift is
separated from the two most lethal
people protecting it Mabel must have
seen the rest of the episode and should
have known
he really should be Mabel has no defense
we are watching this craft as the show
has been completed so she should have
known all that too yeah yeah she should
she should know more than we do
and the world Stakes here yeah man
that's messed up
um I feel like there's gonna be a death
feel like there could be I mean I I was
actually kind of getting worried for no
don't kill sues uh big death I was I was
afraid they were gonna kill Ford
I didn't think for a minute there
I didn't think that was smarter than you
uh can you tell me how to pick up those
things can you teach me the formula so
the next time I get to see a fake out
death I can be like nope it's not it's
not real
too early that's fair he's Gotta Die at
the very end
yeah a brutal death Spike
impaled against the wall impaled like
like it's Cannibal Holocaust yeah just a
slow dying monologue while his fan I
forget he's being peeled off yeah or
something he's bleeding from the ears
yeah yeah it's got to be character
assassination he's gonna go out like and
then and Bill Cipher spits on him yes
yeah he does a full Harry Styles on him
yeah
yeah I mean it's a fort just like
because it's apparently how someone
reaction they get spit on yeah according
to the internet oh it is
this is a bit surprising to be spit on I
didn't expect that he definitely spit on
me just this is a real spit he just
hocked up a loog all over my laps
it's good it's good
I can't wait to see which guest stars
you got to get a little more Gideon
before The Season's done you know he's
not done
I almost feel like you know we had uh
whatever the Justin Roiland character
name is
I did know his name but we got him back
for a second now we're probably gonna
get like a
Greatest Hits before the show's done Mel
Gibson Mel Gibson he he vacations in
Gravity Falls Kevin Spacey's gonna show
up
I would not put that category
no no you should Louis CK will show up
one committed physical assault and
verbally abusive the other did much more
horrendous acts true I like to weigh and
compare terrible acts against each other
you should that's a that is there's
definitely fruit at the end of that
Branch I would put Will Smith's slap and
Dahmer in the same sentence but I would
not put Gibson in space they're both
sins you know
true God judges them all equally they're
all going to help yep yep yep
you know who else is Will Smith's slap
we don't know
have you seen Midnight Mass
watch some television play some videos
some TV play some creative artwork I'm
working on the Last of Us
let's just take it in it
I can't can't play more than one media
in a stretch of Time how how is that
possible
we don't do that here every day where
are you on Last of Us
chapter one
still it's been like that for like two
years no I got Pat it was I was on the
prologue before oh it's just not sure
because once that Uncle dies then now
you're into chapter one yeah
but I'll get there by 2023 just in time
for you to decide to watch the show with
somebody else on camera but either way
all said I did it the last of us mean so
much to me I know it does and I'm loving
it so far I'm already halfway through my
replay of uh last of us too
the one people love
they already replay last of us one
really it's a short game from what I
understand yeah it is but sometimes it
takes people five years well when you
only play like an hour at a time that's
what I did it's always like it's it's
been a few weeks
that's good that's good I need to learn
I need to learn how to break things down
the way you do
uh I could yeah no breaking things down
is the number one thing where I'm like
yeah if I could break this into
bite-sized pieces and schedule them out
that'd be great and then I attempt to do
that and it's like oh my God it's all
swimming particulate and it like spring
literally eat dinner and then while I'm
digesting I play that's a good idea and
I go all right now that I've done
digesting it's time for bed like a weird
robot to be getting you right that's
good that's actually a good idea because
that would keep me I usually eat as the
very last thing that I do because I
don't really like if I try to multitask
while I'm eating then I just wind up
eating so uh yeah that's why I just eat
but you know man scarf down you're like
a slow marinade in my mouth kind of guy
and I'm like uh
and get it in your system and then start
digital
machine yeah yeah the robot my life like
a robot I like to live my life like an
old Samurai where every bite you assess
and you you appreciate lately it's been
right eat
play a game that's good then go to bed
that's good I mean that seems like it's
enriching for your soul
it can be what are you writing
oh I can't tell you that oh
got a big big deal
I'm mapping out the next 10 years I'm
the new Kevin feige and my first plan of
action reboot back girl from scratch and
remove
and footage from Black Adam
yep color correct the one and remove
that Steppenwolf from the other because
that was bad yeah he was in the office
good job this frame of a flame a real
red Explorer red explosion is nuts the
color of Zack Snyder's not blue enough
this is [ __ ] everyone yeah clearly
you are saying that shot Sweden is the
Canon with this red explosion here look
at the mess you made that the average
individual would not realize is from
maybe even Justice
yeah I love it I saw the original uh the
original cut of that and I was like
where oh
really
we can't even see Stephen Wolfie it is
literally just debris and the only
reason you could tell is because it's so
tinted red that you're like oh it must
be from that ugly red zine
so good so important these would be
important that's what I'm working on
good yeah I'm glad you're writing these
trait mothers before you eat and then
Digest
when is The Last of Us come out sometime
in 2023 oh [ __ ] that was November this
year so I was like I gotta finish my
replay unless I'm mistaken but I I
Google I Googled it because I got
curious and I was like how long do I
have because I know it'll take me longer
than it takes you I thought I thought it
was coming out November for some reason
so I was like I better replay this it
could be I I the last I checked it was
sometime early 2023 but
and that was like earlier in the week
but
or is like Ellie my name is Joel earlier
this could be the most stereotypical new
job
Ellie There's No Going Back Ellie he
always has flamenco guitar
[Laughter]
I am the Mandalorian
[Laughter]
this is the way
I am also over in Martel the sexiest
person I don't have Westeros he doesn't
sound Latino at all I know if you didn't
tell me it was Pedro Pascal I would have
assume who's that white guy playing the
Mandalorian yeah he could be my brother
all right he's good I think we've done
it all right bye thanks for being here